bloc québécois jeu d'autres mesures à
ses propositions pour les aînés et
françois blanchet propose de bonifier de
1300 $ par année la pension de sécurité
de la vieillesse aux 50 dollars par mois
du supplément de revenu garanti 600 $
par année
le bloc de monde aussi que ses
prestations soient versées pendant trois
mois au conjoint d'un défunt on propose
aussi une inscription automatique au srg
et une hausse de 5 à 6000 $ de
l'exemption des gains de travail pour
cent sans que cela vienne affecter le
supplément de revenu garanti
on vous propose une analyse ce soir des
propositions pour les aînés avec michel
disent les économistes
retraité du service aux collectivités de
l'uqam bonsoir monsieur disait on soit
monsieur fillion on vous invite parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de mesures qui ont été
présentées depuis le début de la
campagne pour les aînés on comprend bien
qu on veut aider les aînés puis on veut
attirer leurs votes également je vous
invite à nous donner quelques
commentaires sur les propositions alors
avec le bloc québécois puisque on en
parlait propositions sur la sécurité de
vieillesse le supplément de revenu
garanti dans le code du bloc
c'est d'ailleurs ces prenante de tous
les partis celui que les propositions
d'obama les plus généreuses
la première mesure qu'ils proposent est
peut-être une des plus significatives
c'est d'augmenter de 1300 $ par année
la passion de sécurité de vieillesse qui
est universel à son assiette autour de
7000 $
c'est donc une hausse importante et
c'est la première fois depuis de
nombreuses années qu'on parle
d'augmenter la pension de sécurité de
vieillesse qui en raison de son
caractère universel et celle qui fait le
plus le travail d'augmenter le revenu
non seulement les personnes les plus
pauvres mais aussi la classe moyenne
c'est donc une mesure importante les
libéraux auront aussi une proposition va
y revenir tantôt mail à l'art ne
s'appliquera qu'à compter de 75 ans est
le une autre le g deuxième mesure
proposée par le supplément par le blog
augmenter le volume de 600 $ par année
il est actuellement autour de 11 mille
dollars
le problème c'est évidemment c'est que
cette mesure là elle augmente les
revenus des plus pauvres ce qui est une
bonne chose en général n'est pas très
utile pour la classe moyenne
parce que la plupart d'entre elles ont
des revenus modestes de réais représente
de retraite est en général une
augmentation comme ça augmente la
récupération de leurs propres revenus
totaux de son église à 80% donc un pack
est plus mitigé la classe moyenne les le
bloc rappelé aujourd'hui d'ailleurs que
40 % des québécois qui reçoivent la
sécurité de la vieillesse reçoivent
aussi du supplément de revenu garanti
oui à un des enjeux importants qu'il
faut se rappeler plaisait niigata sriti
c'est une partie importante des aînés
qui ont des revenus beaucoup trop faible
et donc entre leurs périodes travaillées
à la retraite il ya une chute importante
de revenus d'où l'importance des deux
régimes fédéraux pension de vieillesse
et sécurité de revenus un enjeu lorsque
les lorsque dans un coq une personne
décède c'est les revenus bien sûr tout
de suite là tout vient se bousculer le
bloc propose que le supplément de revenu
garanti soit complet trois mois de
prestation complète d'un défunt au
conjoint
oui ça l'est davantage d'atténuer le
choc un peu mais éventuellement la même
baisse va survenir mais moins létales un
peu l'inscription automatique au srg
soit c'est un dossier qui date de 20 ans
c'était il ya des personnes de plus de
65 ans qui sont pauvres qui ne sont pas
sur le sujet est revenu garanti
le ministère chargé de verser les
prestations au même produit un rapport
quantifier le nombre de personnes qui ne
ne recevait pas donc ils peuvent les
compter apparemment ils peuvent pas leur
verser l'argent
ah oui et donc c'est un scandale qui
aurait pas de jurés au québec beaucoup
d'organisation de personnes retraitées
et le bloc éventuel npd n'ont pas arrêté
de faire pression sur ce dossier là l'un
d'eux était d'ailleurs exactement la
même demande est là dernier point c'est
une hausse de 5000 $ à 6000 dollars du
revenu d'emploi après cinq ans qui
n'entraînera pas de baisse du supplément
il faut dire prendre je sais ce que les
libéraux au printemps dernier ont fait
une annonce importante pour les enfants
passaient de 3500 à 5000 le revenu
exonéré en plus d'exonérer la moitié des
revenus entre 5000 et 15 mille dollars
donkey libéraux avaient
substantiellement amélioré le bloc
propose d'amélioration sionnel ses
claques c'est une mesure pour favoriser
le métier ou le retour au travail des
plus de 65 ans les libéraux justement
propose une bonification après 75 ans
donc la sécurité de vieillesse serait
augmentée de 729 $ par année mesures
intéressantes pour les 75 ans et plus
est d'abord comme je disais tantôt à
augmenter la pension de sécurité ds
puisque ça fait très longtemps qu'on
fédéral dont la pop menthe et c'est en
soi une très bonne mesure
parce que ça ait de la classe moyenne
la logique des libéraux rejoint un peu
la logique d'une prestation qui avait
été évoqué il ya plusieurs années par le
rapport d'amour se dire on se rend
compte que les beaucoup de personnes la
classe moyenne elle faisait pas une mode
s épuisent leurs épargnes hier autour de
115 ans donc le but c'est au moment où
les dépenses liées à la perte
d'autonomie augmente on introduit une
rente à vie qui vient bonifier donc
c'est un plus et par ailleurs des
libéraux proposent d'augmenter les
prestations de survivants de 2080 $ par
année soit une proposition un peu
cynique
parce que les libéraux savent que pour
être adopté elle doit être adoptée par
les deux tiers des provinces
représentant les deux tiers de la
population
on ne vit avec la bonification du rpc
comment les provinces étaient réticentes
moi je soupçonne que la motivation
politique s'il ya une majorité de
gouvernement conservateurs provinciaux
et je pense que les libéraux veulent
leur maître l'odieux de refuser
d'augmenter les rangs des veuves et des
veufs
mais attendez vous pas de voir votre
rente augmenté ok parfait on verra le
npd donc le supplément de revenu garanti
aux à déterminer et le supplément de
revenu garanti et la pension de sécurité
de vieillesse inscription automatique
également je vous mentionne qu'il ya
peut-être une remarque que je ferai
c'est qu'effectivement semences il n'y a
pas eu de confirmation ça il faut dire
qu'il a une pda cependant une
proposition qui est unique
ils veulent mettre sur pied un comité
aviseur permanent pour s'assurer du
caractère soutenable mais aussi
améliorer la pension le supplément et le
régime de pensions du canada donc à
l'encré fois que ces jeunes ne sont de
son intérêt caddoc ils veulent s'assurer
de façon permanente des gens vont
veiller au grain sur ces dossiers là et
donc le cadre financier du npd n'est
toujours pas déposé ni celui des
conservateurs on nous dit possiblement
vendredi les conservateurs proposent un
crédit en raison de l'âge
c'est la réunification du crédit les
conservateurs au fond ne propose aucune
mesure pour améliorer aucun des trois
programmes dont on a parlé mais il
propose plutôt à la place du crédit
d'impôt c'est bien ça ce crédit là quand
même te dire que ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'on voit
pour moi le l'innovation intéressant ces
deux partis proposent d'améliorer la
pension de signaux tv m6 pour moi est la
clé parce que comme elle n'était
augmenté qu'avec la hausse du coût de la
vie
elle n'arrête pas de voir
c'est rodez par rapport à l'évolution de
salah moyens donc chaque fois qu'on
bonifie la pension de vieillesse ça
bonifie non seulement ça profite non
seulement plus pauvres et les classes
moyennes
il servirait arrêté p cette espèce
d'érosion par rapport au salaire moyen
qui est là pensionnat pour hériter subir
on a on a malheureusement plus de temps
jeu juste mentionné que sur les caisses
de retraite le npd le bloc considère
veulent que les caisses de retraite
soient considérés comme créancier
prioritaire en cas de faillite
oui je pense que les dossiers de s'y
rendre ou ont indiqué que c'est un non
sens il faut dire que même les libéraux
ont dit qu'ils vont commencer à y
réfléchir mais il ya une pression très
forte et des milieux d'affaires et des
munitions financier avec ses objets qu
et l'otan jeu qui divise ses blocs npd
s'oppose à l'adoption d'un projet de loi
sur les régimes à prestations cible
alors que les libéraux bien ou alors on
en reparlera faut vraiment s'arrêter
parce que on va perdre une antenne dans
un instant merci beaucoup plus utilisés
merci bien